of the divisions right we're gonna have
one or two that have multiple playoff
teams which divisions and let's start
with the AFC which divisions do you
think are the most likely to generate
that second playoff team well this is
this is a tough one
because I mean I don't know Mike is it
me first off or am I crazy I just feel
like there's more talent and good
coaching combinations and teams across
the league than I ever remember like you
know I know we're gonna have to make
Super Bowl predictions playoff
predictions coming along here and I'm
trying to start it slowly going through
that my head and it's tough because it's
not like what divisions gonna have to in
the playoffs
it's more like what divisions not gonna
have to in the playoffs and to me
there's only one division right off the
bat that I can go I feel confident in
saying only one team will make the
playoffs in that division and that's the
AFC East with the New England Patriots
okay now all the other ones I'm with you
but in the AFC like you're asking what's
the one division I look at to go I think
to two teams will be there I guess if
you made me pick one I'm going to go
with the AFC North but I don't feel like
comfortable about just picking that one
but I'm gonna go with the North because
I think there's three quality playoff
caliber teams there in that division but
see that's the problem Chris the more
quality playoff caliber teams you have
the more they chew up on each other and
the harder it is for the second place or
the third place team to have a shot at
the five seed or the six seed I thought
you were gonna go AFC West because even
though it feels like the Raiders and the
Broncos are gaining some ground I still
think the Chiefs and the Chargers have
some separation over them and when you
said the division that you think will
only send one for sure the AFC East we I
thought were you're in agreement but
doing the bills and the Jets one of
those teams is gonna rise up and
threaten for a spot I thought you were
gonna say the AFC South is the division
that you think would only send one but
then you look at them between the Colts
and the Jaguars and who knows what the
Texans do I just think that that most of
these divisions now I agree with you the
East is the only one that has that
obvious first-place team that has owned
the division for the last generation
with the exception of 2008 when Tom
Brady had a torn ACL but in the other
ones they're so packed together and
they're
is a chance they will beat up on each
other so much and pull their record down
this is why the Patriots are the 1 seed
more often than not they don't have to
worry about these other teams in their
division
dragging their record down that's gonna
be the problem in the north the West and
maybe the south
ya know III hear you you're right and
you know I'm with what you said with the
bills in the Jets I expect great
improvements I think if you made me bet
money right now I'm not gonna pick them
to make the playoffs I think they're
gonna be a pain in the butt for
everybody and they're gonna be like just
on the outside looking in going in the
right direction if I had a pick there
but no I mean the point you make about
the Patriots very real it's like the
49ers back in the 80s they got to play
in that old NFC West that you know
really didn't have any Super Bowl
caliber teams but you know again when
you bring it back and you say the AFC
West with the Chargers and the Chiefs -
ok you know we've heard you know Philip
Rivers make comments like we could have
gone 6 and 10 last year you know they
won a lot of games by the skin or the
teeth and the other thing just looking
at their overall their overall schedule
this year the thing that scares me a
little bit about the AFC West just to
get into that is they got to play the
AFC South which i think is another
division we look at and go well it could
very possibly have two teams they also
got to play the NFC North which is one
of the best divisions in football - so I
looked at that let alone just not the
division matchups and uh you know again
I go with the AFC North just because of
you got the Ravens a Super Bowl winning
head coach you've got Ben Roethlisberger
and Mike Tomlin Super Bowl quarterback
and head coach and then you got this
Cleveland Browns football team that I
just think has an incredible talent and
good coaching to go along with it as
well - we're yeah if you made me pick
one I'm going to go with that but in the
AFC you're going with the West you think
that's the your your locker do you think
we'll have two teams in the playoffs I
hate to admit it but you've kind of
convinced me to revisit my thinking in
that regard and it's you know I was
writing something about the Raiders on
Hard Knocks last night looking at all
the stuff that John Bruton has to worry
about and I went through the schedule of
all those teams they play in those those
schedules are roughly identical for the
first place through the fourth place
teams from last season in the AFC West
they've all got to play the teams of the
AFC South they've all got to play the
teams of
the NFC North and that is gonna make it
harder for today it's gonna be very
other than the Patriots who is gonna
rack up the kind of record that it's
gonna make us say Wow and even in the
north we're expecting the Browns to earn
a playoff berth and some think the
Browns win the division they got a deal
with the Ravens and the Steelers and the
Bengals are not gonna go well you got
some tough talk from them saying that
they could be like the Rams offense in
and of all those teams the Bengals are
in the best spot from the standpoint of
preseason expectations because nobody's
paying any attention to them at all no
you're right and you really evaluate
that bangels roster and I know we've had
this conversation before there's more
talent there than you think when you
just you hear the word Cincinnati
Bengals you just go okay it's the
bangles actel they're kind of unproven
head coach okay Andy Dalton it's not
that great but then you look at the rest
of the team and you go man they're just
a lot of good players there but I still
think that's a team that's maybe a few
players away not gonna be quite there
yet and Zac Taylor's gonna have to get
his feet underneath them I don't think
they're going playoffs this year but man
it's a tough one in the AFC to if you
make it just you know nail down which
division and then you get in the NFC
Mike and I don't know if it's any better
it might be worse than that in that
conference because who do you pick in
the NFC Mike who is the division that if
you had to say guaranteed has two teams
and then in the playoffs who would it be
I think that if I had to pick one of the
four I'd say the NFC East just because I
see a huge gap between the Cowboys and
the Eagles and Washington and the Giants
and I think it's gonna allow them to
fatten up their records enough the
Cowboys in Philadelphia that whoever
finishes second place is going to
compare favorably to the second-place
teams from the other three divisions
because we talked last week about how in
the NFC North they're so packed together
you could win it you could be in fourth
place or anything in between the NFC
West has three really good teams the NFC
South I don't I don't know that there's
a second place team that's gonna be good
enough to make it I don't know but I
think in the east because the Giants in
Washington I believe will be down it
makes it easier for whoever doesn't win
it to get enough wins under their belt
to be that five seater the six seed I
lean a little bit towards you
towards what you're saying as well you
know the NFC South you brought that up I
mean this that's three quality teams we
know of and we expect the Bucks to be
better but yeah I'm not sure what the
Panthers and Falcons will be so I'm with
you there I'm not picking the NFC South
I think really if you put a gun to my
head I'm with you I'm going NFC East
that's where I'm gonna do it because I
just think the Eagles and Cowboys have
two of the best rosters and in the in
the NFC and then the whole league in
general there's just not a lot of
weakness there but gosh when I say that
I sit there and go gosh you look at the
NFC West you got the Rams the Seahawks I
mean I think we both look at them as
playoff caliber teams and then the NFC
North I know I expect Rodgers and
LeFleur and and them to get back in the
playoffs and I expect the Chicago Bears
to be there as well so it's a really
tough one I don't know why but it just
seems like the league has more parity
this year than I can remember any time
in recent history and I think it's gonna
be hard to to pick my playoff my playoff
tree when it comes time to do that here
on PFD I think that the NFC North is the
division most likely to send only one
team to the post guy but because of the
fact that they are bunched together they
play all four teams of the AFC West they
play the four teams of the NFC East now
look Washington and New York should be
easy wins for all those teams who knows
but the Eagles and the Cowboys will not
be pushovers at all it's gonna be some
tough games and and I could see any team
winning it and I could see only that
team advancing to the postseason that's
how that's how hard fight it's gonna be
old black and blue division all over
again this year and they're gonna be
gunning for the Bears they're gonna be
sleeping on the Lions the Packers are
gonna be doing their best to prove that
the past couple of years are more
aberration than norm and the Vikings
desperate to show that this Kirk Cousins
experiment is going to pay dividends I
think there's gonna be desperation from
week one urgency from week one and it
may make whoever wins that division very
well-suited to compete in the postseason
but I think that division is gonna is
gonna be the most likely to only put one
team in out of the
FC okay so the NFC if you you're picking
the NFC East and the NFC West to have
two deaths through your conference this
year we're gonna they're gonna have
multiple teams and the playoffs
probably just because in the West
between the Rams Seahawks and 49ers I'm
confident two of them will be good I
don't know which - I'm gonna go Seahawks
as one of them between Rams and 49ers I
feel like one's going to overachieve and
one's going to underachieve and there's
going to be two highly competitive NFC
West Eve's I don't want overlook the
Cardinals but the Cardinals have to
prove it to us if calimary if calimary
ends up being the next big thing and
injects this this higher level of skill
than the Cardinals have seen in a young
quarterback ever and has a Baker
Mayfield Patrick mahomes type type of an
impact and well you know it's a big if
until we see the guy play but there's a
chance that first Monday after the
opening slate of games were saying holy
crap Kyler Murray really is the goods
that's going to change our thinking as
well well yeah it will it's not that you
know I'm with you in the fact that
Arizona is not a playoff caliber
football team but if Kyler Murray proves
to be what we all think he'll be he's
gonna win some games or at least be a
pain in the butt for some NFC west
football teams to wear yeah they might
lose some games just because of his his
talents and what he brings to the table
but I also I want to piggyback off of
something you said I'm with you the Rams
and the 49ers are really to me two teams
that are gonna dictate how this whole
playoff picture plays out you know the
Rams I'm with you I think we're gonna
see a little bit of a letdown type year
and I'm not saying that doesn't mean
they don't make the playoffs and I do
expect the 49ers to have the best year
they've had in the Kyle Shanahan regime
or era I should say so
within that yes does it one hurt the
other two where one doesn't make the
playoffs oh they both make it I don't
know how it goes out I think if I had to
pick my two divisions that have to win
the NFC I'm going NFC East like you like
I said I think I am gonna go the NFC
North I think I'm going to pick probably
Bears and Packers when all said and done
to make the playoffs
I just think between Aaron Rodgers will
floor you know that old line the new
energy in the building and then the
great free agent period that the Packers
had strengthen their defense along with
the draft I just think the Packers are
kind of be a little bit of a resurgence
mode and the NFL this year
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports